hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play or hello and welcome
shut up I know wait all right let's do
that again
now let's do it again let's play I want
to do it again no I like to fail we
don't believe it as it is
hello everyone welcome let's play drunk
team that's not what I sound like
that's exactly what Mark sounds like I'm
pretty sure it's pretty close oh okay
so what do we do Arkansas okay Oh bother
you - leave it on for a while okay start
no I'm not permitted to build though all
right let me get the permissions going
okay butters there's some like shears
here what you have to do is break the
center wool block of any one of those
wires and then press the button on the
far left to check to see how many wires
that you have correct before the timer
counts down and then inevitably kills us
all
okay on the bright side listen anything
anybody says I'm just gonna randomly
press stuff okay don't hit the - one
minute - ten second - don't hit those
don't hit those those gives us they give
us they're over here in the beginning
but I shouldn't have said that
shut up butters oh we have permission to
die yet no not yet zombies getting those
permissions
every single world that I import I have
to set up permissions it's a little
weird but okay good I do not Bobby I can
play I Sears what I do with them I'm
still not permitted oh there we go
shears are for okay let's start this
[ __ ] but I win who's knocking down time
Oh God we're so but who's hitting those
Bob we got 20 seconds we're supposed to
be doing
no no there's 28 seconds on the clock
okay 17 16 hours
way to go loser 10 you're butters voices
laugh is creepy
we failed apparently does that mean we
water loss I think we won I feel like a
winner you know I feel like oh yeah I
know so uh Tommy yeah Bob I need you to
say my precious is I needs it I needs it
interesting the Lord of the Rings
episode oh yeah I'm in the middle of
them I'm fighting zombies with shears
yeah sounds about right
I mean it sounds like a sound strategy
zombies got to get it all set up no food
no food yay it's imported yay we're back
now I've leaves
I've grass all right so what we're
supposed to do though we're supposed to
cut the wires you're supposed to cut you
cut like one or two wires and then you
press this button over here and a light
should tell you up here how many you've
got cut correctly oh okay
which will then defuse the bomb so you
wins or if you stop the timer okay all
right so let's just okay I'm gonna hit
the start button
no one's gonna hit the minus x button
okay all right it's clock has started
okay I'm gonna cut this click wait hang
on something happened all right
I think one is cut correctly I don't
know how do we check that I don't know
like these flash I swear these flash a
bit we're gonna die okay
that um that okay I don't think we're
right at all I think we need to replace
something how do we do that
back I didn't pick up any wool okay I
think the purple one's supposed to be
cut because it stopped flashing
okay so what's on the other side I cut
green okay let me hit the button again
see how that goes okay just one is just
one is still flashing so I think the
purple one is the correct one but yeah I
cut red put the green back what are you
doing we're gonna die we got 50 seconds
oh boy oh boy oh boy we're gonna die oh
no the right I don't think the red
helped either
oh it's flashing a good thing or a bad
thing I don't know
ooh world bunny oh we're gonna die hey
what are you doing to help butters doing
what oh there's more on the other side
oh I get it I get it I get it I get it
oh [ __ ] we're so [ __ ] that for three did
we get it somehow
did we win I don't know it didn't blow
up oh I got oh text oh hey we won yes I
don't know I don't know how we won't
lend purple and blue we're cut over here
does anything how do we get it to blow
up hell mo go down here oh I thought we
win well I felt I felt lemony I'm an
idiot I'm an idiot I died
zombi blow it up blow it up so you know
where you add the time and take off the
time there's a button that can turn the
explosion on or off oh so it was off so
you guys failed but we're stuck in here
we're stuck in here oh there we go
that's more like it ah all right cool
how do we get to the bunny Oh what the
heck is the this it's not looking like a
bunny that does oh that's a bunny yeah
that ha ha it's twitching
that's so cute oh holy hell doing Bob
way to go it's so weird I don't think
we're supposed to man
disco made a lot of good maps yeah why
am i dying how do you people how it is
easy I I thought I was jumping we're
losing by a lot
what don't hit me we're supposed to be
working together to kill the bus stop it
Oh Bob
stop it I can't even get passed out or
dying
oh man that butters voice okay you just
earned the butters voice to be turned up
[ __ ] why topic you're a dick
stop it okay we're totally serious
serious now serious well I didn't do
anything we're supposed to kill this
thing bunny how do you jump to this
plant you have to sprint jump Oh what oh
not like that okay I don't know what
we're supposed to do here but it hurts
this bunny is killing us I got a bow I
have a bow that was my bow oh I'm dead
yeah this seriously that bunny is like
serious business when it comes to you
just had to take the bow and jump it on
fire this is not working out wait so
zombie please what is the goddamn point
pretty sure from what I can tell you
shoot it with arrows or certain weak
points and then we'll take his health
down and eventually it'll die oh can we
get our yeah what's weird I think
there's a chest somewhere up here that
has your starting gear let me find that
out that would be nice huh how is just
work ow
it can shoot everywhere Oh No
we're dying so much Oh what well oh
there's a chest ah I see
Oh Mike you guys all screw yourself how
do we get out press the there's a button
in there there's not a button
I've got arrows but no bow there's no
button there is a button but I can't
press I can't do anything there's no
button no one punch these [ __ ] oh
there's the button move-move-move with
this button what the got it oh who did
that
what destroy the button there's a lever
hang on got it got it got it got it got
it got it got it okay get in there Wade
get in there get in there I didn't get
anything you piece of sh all care oh
okay I got it
I've got like a million arrows and Oh No
all right I'm gonna kill this thing you
guys are just gonna screw yourselves I
don't know what I'm aiming for oh crap
who's the bow I do you're such a douche
why cuz I got the bow move I'm sure move
I'm shooting it move this here dick yeah
I'm trying to kill the boss I think
there's a weak point in his groin we got
a gun
are there no more votes oh wait you know
I got I've got one arrow I'm gonna hit
it I'm gonna hit this I can't see ya
[ __ ] damn thing yeah mark hit that I
will or death 20 yeah
I'm hitting it right in the ah [ __ ] ow
well there goes the bow this is
ridiculously hard there's only one bow
it's ridiculous
can we get like something to help us out
oh we're not doing well oh my god I'm
gonna go back to like world Warcraft or
expose dyers something this is
ridiculous oh god how does it know where
I am okay I don't think I've hit
anything I hit that little belly button
of it
nothing happened though alright
oh no I was just getting to the top of
the lover no okay I was I was on top of
our spawn alright next almost done oh we
could've gotten it we're all very
visible dick no we're invisible right
now oh I see a cool one okay hold on
okay oh okay are we recording yeah I
don't remember doing an intro we did I
screwed it up oh well that's every
single one shut up you guys screwed up
for me on the other times there's the
only time I've actually screwed it up
yeah
oh well 64 don't care
ooh world cake I like to sound that I'm
hungry
whoo oh wow that's got hands I can't see
you guys for some reason I can't see
anybody either
Xabi why can't we see each other that's
that thing it's like you need to load
the packets like a tree log I'm pretty
low I really like okay here we go
ah there you are Bob okay you see me oh
I see you guys okay here we are
so what are we doing this one so it's
kind of like a like a mob arena
I think hello bonds mobs there's like a
cool UI and herobrine's mouths or
whatever and I see that here hit this
chest and stuff in there thank you
didn't already take all the stuff I took
one row there's like three rows so it's
perfect for all of us
I took one bow I'm not taking a whole
row of them my stuff does disappear
you're an ass Bob what what you do I
don't do anything am I not supposed to
have all of the arrows bows and swords
my swords just left my inventory
actually I started mine I got mine that
is creepy as hell by the way just saying
there's like [ __ ] creepy all of a
sudden I've got tons of bows but all my
swords are gone hey let's not kill each
other all right let's do this get that
button we're the swords it here I got a
spot here here house there's the button
huh bong bong bong Bing Oh zombie her a
zombie not zombie oh but there's zombie
oh that's got cool Wow I'm shooting
arrows so just be careful o re Bobby got
one behind you do we get armor or
anything like that
oh there's most rib uted for after the
waves oh okay
kind of a random drop system I think
they fall in the middle of the map okay
well it's gonna be a murder fest trying
to get this stuff alright let's just
stick with swords for now because we're
gonna kill each other if we keep doing
it yeah arrows dobby's our way to turn
PvP off
I would love oh good
cuz working together seems like oh we
shouldn't whoa watch out wait I got your
back oh you can just push him off the
map bong bong Bing that's kind of cool I
really like that
oh it highlights what monster I just got
some leather armor really I got armor
and boots hey I got diamond sword some
how do I not get loot you go suck a [ __ ]
suck a bag of dicks is there anything in
the I got no loot don't care I had to
eat rotten flesh Wow Skellig that's
Skellington okay okay wow these guys
hurt I'm gonna die I need to hide for a
bit you guys take care of it
woah
oh he little [ __ ] I'll die I will rape
you
okay all right that's good I'm gonna hit
the button well there's still skeletons
okay hey I hit the bike no I was a
terrible idea is perfectly good idea Bob
weren't you talking I'm trying to kill
skeletons Bob you need to be more
energetic climb poles I didn't get any
loot and Mark did it I don't know
diamond sword all right were you just
shooting at me Bob yes why because I
secretly hate you except that it's not a
secret
hi I got all the loot yeah
congratulations now are you gonna be
gonna be high no nope you guys are dicks
my doesn't seem right yes sir dicks I
just told you suck a dick earlier so so
I should sell skeleton zombies odd guns
they're implications right there whoa
holy crap oh my god who pushed the
button more than once oh my god I'm so
many of them oh god I'm gonna die oh my
god you guys suck
[ __ ] I'll wait I'm right here hey we
spawned right here I didn't die I don't
see you guys anymore
I don't see anything anymore oh boy I'm
still fighting where are you guys I see
nothing I got a real OGG okay come back
in there we go
I see now I can see clearly now the rain
is gone don't you sing with me I can see
all obstacles in my way
oh why dude II didn't a spiders where
the spiders come from oh crap beer bag
way to go away probably the same place
that's like the rest of that stuff okay
here we go next wave I don't know where
Wade went Wade went away I got a diamond
sword
that's probably my diamond sword that I
died and drop oh god I'm gonna die
uh-uh
feck you guys need to not die this is
not going well I was gonna give you a
pro tip it would be that you should not
die really Bob really that's your pro
tip yes I'm adding you're not ignore
your you're my progeny [ __ ] how you
want some arbor no I'm okay Oh screen
spiders damn
I'm only punching on my fist so this is
not work [ __ ] gut dip spider s bag oh
my it's not going wrong I am gonna die
oh oh there we go now I have a sword oh
it's my health not going up just [ __ ]
you that's what at least some of the
skeletons are hitting each other so
that's nice oh we're clearing about now
why did I die ten billion times none of
you died to anything cuz I have time and
armor do you want some armor mark is
well veiny yes please I don't have any
armor where'd it all go oh you made me
sad there's some over here then if I
didn't pick it up oh no there's not yeah
you made me sad no okay next one here
I'm dropping armor next wave next wave
no this map that's being imported is
slightly large so it's kind of slowing
us down a minute okay can I be a sweater
lane yeah up timeout there we go I timed
out I didn't do this money gonna say to
big surfer broken no it's just I
wouldn't have bothered try it's and it's
like converting so I don't know it's
it's on it's like 20% get a second
alright let's go blow it marks town well
we okay all right then I am dead
someone's talking about me
well darkness move what happened I'm
playing TNT Oh the guys who whose house
you blew up is here really yeah
oh that's darkness yeah
thief thief I want my soul darkness Oh
thief fraud I'm gonna hang if I could I
have no money so I can't port to
anything you should have found an
emerald or there we go mark I'm running
through your tunnel of doom it's not
really a tunnel to him anymore someone
went through it and kind of broke it
well how'd they get in I don't know they
blew up the opening
oh hey I'm back
oh I'll cheese oh okay Bob back uh yeah
anyway the guy who owned the house that
we blew up came on and kind of like
questioning why and he's a dirty dirty
thief the other houses that we blew up
kind of just collateral damage we're
back on the other server I don't know
zombies it all ready to go uh fifty
percent okay I wish I had some TNT and
flint and steel wait why'd you kill
yourself it was your tunnel oh that
makes sense
ah okay oh I lost all my good stuff aha
and now I just need flint and steel in
there a piece I had all this enchanted
diamond stuff no one cares everybody
cares I learned how much time is left in
the episode sixteen seventeen minutes
why just wondering I want to blow up
this town that we spotted at dinner time
it's the dinner time it is wait is it
Monday
yes fat [ __ ] [ __ ] was Tuesday wings
yeah wings but whatever can't have
everything
you know I thought I thought this whole
server was gonna go up in smoke or this
whole map so I thought everything was
gonna be gone
wait is that you on that hill
who's that I'm in some random town
oh it's darkness
it's darkness it's the thief it's
darkness
I can't war because I've got no money
Harkness
yeah it's darkness mark teleport me to
you I can't I don't have those powers
well I have a bunch of gold whoa
I just got a bunch of gold out of
nowhere all right 90% I'm starving I
need food I don't know what to do here
how do I leave this place where did I
get 12 gold blocks whoo darkness gave me
food hit man what'd I do
like you don't know yeah yeah we know we
know we know and we destroyed your home
Maps up oh hey I think I said the wrong
thing
come back here darkness I'm gonna getcha
I'm gonna getcha
[Music]
you must be punished if the maps up
should we go back to the other server I
must punish punish I'm in the other
server why you okay over episode why are
you come from what do you do
oh hello we're back here it's okay stop
being such a baby I got tricked stop
being such a baby
point-blank I got oh I died no joke
you're on fire now for some reason - hey
so we got guys who are watching who's we
seem to ignore all the time
we got another map coming up we're gonna
do something with it I don't know what
what random loot is this gold apples
string bones bread redstone not spider
up down Oh Bob's not breaking the level
I didn't do it you're doing stuff right
now I see you doing it but you're
invisible oh really
you may have to relock cuz I can see you
Oh what what huh Bob what are you doing
bob is breaking the law oh boy did you
hit the button Bob maybe do how many
times did you hit the button like and
then Bob Bob I don't think it's doing
anything
oh it's doing some you guys ready for
the next vote yes please
we're about to die oh hi Bob there we go
okay hey all right so I'm gonna clear
your inventories basically this one is
like an RPG there's a lot of texts the
guy kind of has like a storyline going
on here um it's not quite as linear as
the last one so you guys are kind of
like free to move around I mean it does
have a main place that you need to go to
but there's all kinds of lewd and all
kinds of crazy stuff so I'm sure you
figure it out
follow Gillis Village Road to create
sweeter vania so where are you guys I'm
in a bill found a weird sign where are
you I'm in a building I don't see you
I'm a real OGG okay there you are
I see Wade now I see Bob okay can you
see me we've made this sign it's part of
the game Bob somehow I don't think ass
titties
ass and titties is part of the game it's
better the game somehow I don't think so
okay I'm following the road goodies are
Alania a place where we can get weapons
the fangs of winter
what feet are cold it's snowy Wow give
me boots don't have them boots what a
horrible night to have a curse
are you guys following me no follow me
no follow me zombie spent a lot of time
getting this map in we owe it to him I'm
trying to follow you Bob's killing
things Gillis Village Road where are you
Mart
I followed the road Stillwater Lake doc
okey dokey this is very atmospheric and
gritty
so get with the program oh I'm trying
but you're gone
I followed the road right there Bob's
job Bob got it Enderman Enderman we're
look at him he's right there
this is a creeper in the forest
okay Sambi is actually joining us for
this map why did you hit the Enderman no
reason [ __ ] I'm gonna die
Obama die I'm going to die
all right you have armor I don't have
them where did you get armor I don't
know I have armor
sorry zombie doll you hit zombie what I
need food and/or armor HECO dead man sky
didn't get any of that
oh are you worried Fargo I'm giving you
okay thank you
and apples wait why did you get food
because zombie gave me food follow just
keep following the road don't ask
questions I went in that man's cave is
that that mistake I don't know let's go
to soon shalt thou be late to learn what
from this dead man's cave shall none
return if the dragons are aiive seek
under szura the ancient sleeps I should
probably read these better shouldn't I
yes
[ __ ] maggot oh I don't see any more
signs
is it dead end dead end dead end dead
end dead end
man what is going on here creeper I have
no food and no health don't care hello
I'm going down oh I'm going down out
going down oh we can't harvest anything
look you know ya know it's adventure
mode I don't think we need to actually
Oh
morg starting off on the right foot why
I couldn't I'm in the wrong place
I'm back in the arena Oh God is this oh
god oh holy crap that's on a monster
spawner I can't kill it though I found
all the treasures no mine
nah damn it dick damn you it was mostly
just ores who cares about that
okay whatever just getting out of here
oh gosh sure go slow Oh God
there's like a farmhouse over here that
was outside the cave that guy still in
the cave yeah where are you wait
somewhere in the cave I'm gonna go
farther end I got a bunch of armor
diamond armor actually to be specific
cuz I'm epic and I got poured into the
arena where there was a bunch of gear on
the ground those food and I found a clip
and they're mine I got nothing where to
go for you hello a crowd or all I have
it's Rob why is this place entirely lit
up but there's nothing here there's
stuff I found stuff okay we're gonna get
lost in here you can pour this out hurry
not to meet death what do I see another
chest how do I get to it
hurry not to meet death these sons don't
make any sense
aha here be the trove of Captain Steve
Colbert I like it I like it a lot I read
my patron intense yeah actually can we
get poured it outside of the yeah but
there's a chest in here
I found one chest ooh I see the monster
ponder you were talking about oh wow
yeah we can get out of this cave there's
like a village over here oh not again
okay
thought was gonna be on fire okay so
we're back somewhere else let us venture
into the village mind friends I'm in
renewed fishing village of gillis
travelers well card give me some food I
don't have any food oh yes I do I have a
cake here cake no give me food okay I'm
right here by the way the cake I'm
trying to set the cake down how do I set
the cake down I can't place cake well
fine are hard okay here's a cooked fish
right there's a cake but you can't eat
the cake here's cook
no that's diamond which there i found
food i got a diamond armor yes how are
you guys getting diamond armor i found
it before hook sinkers and lures free
with any purchase fishing rod yeah I
found a fishing rod does it work
can I fish Foix yes I can
oh yeah watch this epic excitement of
drunk minecraft oh I just found a secret
hidden chest don't care ah what Dell I
didn't get a fish
I also just found some bows and arrows
and a boat into fishing rod that's where
that's where I was I found my fishing
around there I found in Zombie I think
we're supposed to be doing something
there's like a castle at the end of this
okay I apparently I can't get fish out
of there so Bob screw that okay so let's
just keep moving let's keep moving
there's some leather crap over here okay
I'm gonna go away dr. van Helsing really
ooh doggies found apples found bread get
get out of the way there we go
oh here's the road I found the road
follow me my friends follow me where'd
you go oh you were right behind me what
happened uh this way maybe no not this
way not this way where are you guys
whoa I don't think you guys oh I was
right by you why haha I'm going the
right way
this map is really intense it is kind of
it's it's also really large yeah it's
huge so big so thank you guys thank you
so gothy yeah it's all about the girth
of the map I think I what the incorrect
direction yeah no [ __ ] such an idiot
I'm king of the mountain oh no I'm not
king of the mountain anymore ah ooh
seeds but I can't do anything with seeds
wait back where we were I jumped off the
mountain and my acrobatic skill went up
where are you guys is back where we were
yeah this is back where we were is wrong
this is so wrong they hang on I'm gonna
go back well there's some story in this
house who cares read it read it read it
and then the dude was like why are you
naked
and the other guy hi stranger why aren't
you I see and I see where the barn if
you need it I see where we're supposed
to go here I see it I see you guys need
to follow me or something report to me
or I don't care do whatever you want I'm
gonna do my thing
Laura found it I found it I found it
I need to stop that Bob zombie port them
to us
why are you attacking zombie what why we
got bored why because it was boring it's
not boring you need to get in the
adventure man it's pretty boring
shut up there's like freaking castle
here not for me I'm dead you want to
blow it up cuz we're almost out of time
anyway this looks like the perfect thing
to blow up just just saying it's so
beautiful it should be destroyed see
sorry if we're ruining your experience
in this map zombie that's alright
guy got here at time get up here can you
replace like all the wood with TNT or
something or I don't know do what you
want that would be pretty epic whoa oh
no what oh I see the wrong I don't think
that was right I'm gonna fish boo
Oh God silver really hey I didn't die
hey good for you now get back up here
cuz you're gonna die in the explosion if
you're down there I don't think it's
died am I supposed to be here no
although I could set it off no no no
yeah just get rid of it that way this
was supposed to be our vantage point
okay whatever I'm going to watch the
explosion from here close enough what
all that TNT over there
you know the TNT that's mysteriously
spawning in random places that TNT oh
crap Oh woohoo holy crap is a bad idea
wait that's a terrible terrible terrible
idea
wait what's gonna happen what startle be
igniting it from wait you're doomed Oh
oh my god it's beautiful it's gorgeous I
love it oh you know if they rebuilt
minecraft I'm like a different engine up
there goes that's all she wrote and we
TV oh and we're back
okay we're still blown up okay
everyone's left the game anyway so oh
yeah that was delightful
yikes and we are out of time okay shut
up
thank you you gotta thank first and then
thanked us [ __ ] bye bye
really Bob
is that not appropriate that's not that
is inappropriate I bet it is Wow Wow
that come from I don't know we're dead
Oh anyway that's all the time we got
from before this episode so thank you
all for sticking with us in drunk
minecraft of you enjoyed it if you did
let us know stop it
I got diamonds so [ __ ] you up I will
don't even try it oh oh no you did it oh
are you not dying dude god mode on I
don't know okay anyway thank you all so
much for watching
wait stop thank you everybody so much
for watching
it's why'd this been mark wire with
waiting there we go there we go there we
go thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always see you in the
next one in the next video